le commentaire du cardinal lustiger
fallait-il sacrifier 300 africains pour
obtenir enfin un débat sur une question
aussi fondamentale que l'immigration les
autres réactions de gauche et de droite
recueilli par françoise david et gilles
de blair on a le sentiment que le
gouvernement a manqué la tannée vidant
savoir vivre qui aurait été la marque
d'un savoir faire sur un dossier
difficile et dans ces conditions on est
submergé par une vraie émotion et en
même temps on se dit que cette
intervention de forces ne règle rien que
va-t-il se passer maintenant
comment vont se régler les situations de
ces familles qui étaient sans papiers à
la suite des lois pasqua le gouvernement
en prenant une décision choquante mais
en plus rien réglé cette intervention se
situe bien dans dans l'esprit de la
vieille droite brutale et cynique il
faut bien le dire pour des calculs
politiciens sordide
cela démontre encore là l'incapacité du
gouvernement à régler les problèmes de
régler ces questions humaines à être
sourd à à l'opinion publique
hier le premier ministre après avoir
consulté le conseil d'état a dit la loi
et a dit qu'il était prêt à aller au
delà d'une lecture rigide de la loi qui
était prêt à examiner les cas
individuels
c'est ce que réclamaient les personnes
de saint bernard
j'espérais que fier soirs où tout au
long de la nuit un petit geste qui se
manifeste du côté des sans papiers pour
dire et bien là il ya quand même eu
l'amorcé d'un dialogue et avec l'amorcé
d'un dialogue on peut espérer une issue
qui soit autre que celle de ce matin
je crois que dans cette affaire le
gouvernement appliquer la mission qui
est la sienne qui est d'appliquer la loi
nous étions arrivés à une phase de
rapport de force extrêmement tendue
malgré les ouvertures qui avait été fait
et je crois qu'à ce stade
même si chacun peut le regretter il
fallait que les règles de l'état de
droit soit respecté jusqu'au bout